right
okay you know live thank you very much
uh tom
well uh good evening fellow councillors
we meet again
um on the extraordinary meeting
and uh 5 30 start
so begin with first of all apologies and
then we'll do the register okay
or whichever way round you want to do
whichever is easiest
ready who's doing who's doing this
besties
hello oh my god
yeah that'd be great mary thank you yeah
okay
can i do the attendance registered
assemblies
council about him yes here
councillor brenton president
[Music]
councillor bright yeah
councillor brown here
councillor christie
yeah excuse me what about councillor
bushby
i did ask you didn't respond sorry
you're there
counselor craigie
chancellor dark
yes present thank you
councillor ford president
cancer cup present can i just say that a
lot of people are unmuted and so we
can't hear you calling the names though
thank you
okay councillor hackett
president mr haynes
preston council harding
councillor harding
councillor hawkins yeah
councillor apple
councillor heppel
councillor hicks president
hutchins yep
chancellor inch president
councillor jones jones
cancel the laws
yeah thank you councillor locke
president councillor mcauliffe
yes president thank you
councillor mckenzie president
thank you councillor manley president
councillor newton president
councillor pennington president
councillor rossi
councillor rossi
councillor watson president
councillor wiseman
counselor wiseman
chair are you happy for me to just run
through the few who haven't responded
again okay yeah okay councillor craigie
councillor harding here sorry i couldn't
log on
thank you no worries thank you
councillor heppell
and councillor rossi
finally councillor wiseman
okay thank you thank you okay so do we
have any apologies for absence
chair i've not received any apologies ah
right okay
right i think i think there's some
there's pointed out earlier on
uh people being uh unmuted made a bit of
a
cause a bit of a problem never mind
we're on we go um
so public contributions we don't have
any do we
no that's correct yeah right
declarations of interest well members
you know you should declare interest
and describe the nature when the item
comes along as
printed in front of you agreements
transgender part one and two we do have
uh items in part two uh do we need to
vote on that i thought we were going to
get rid of this bit and
just go to the vote when the time came
for those items
correct me somebody if i'm wrong
or do we take a vote now
j i don't think it came out of the
constitution
it didn't so we must spoke up all right
so we need to take a vote on
the the part two items okay
so here we go i'll propose it share
thank you i'll
thank you right okay okay
councillor brown at four
councillor brenton four
councillor bright four
councillor brown
councillor brown
thank you councillor bushby
or council christie
or councillor clark
or councillor coddle honking
councillor hackett or
councillor haines or
chancellor harding or councillor hawkins
or councillor
council inch four
councillor james or councillor jones
four cancel a language
so
i'm against
councillor mackenzie for
councillor manly or
councillor newton four
councillor pennington or
councillor watson oh
yeah that's one against and thirty
one four thank you very much
right so item five then um i've just got
a couple of items on uh
things being brought by the chair first
of all is i think we ought to
have an opinion on the fact that we are
as an area
being put into level two vis-a-vis the
uh
covid um restrictions i have to say i do
find this
a bit extraordinary that we're in this
position
because well as you know the case
numbers don't know i have to declare an
interest as far as i've told you before
my uh eldest daughter is a staff nurse
on a covered ward i have a son who's a
teacher
and a granddaughter at university so i'm
as keen as anybody to ensure that this
uh
virus doesn't spread more than uh
can be prevented so um having said that
it doesn't seem any logic in the way
they've uh
treated us here in northern devon it
seems convenient that the uh
the county and the government can uh cut
us off when it suits them
in terms of funding and yet when we come
to this issue
where we're in an area with high numbers
of self-employed people
and people depend on the hospitality
industry that that we are
in an area that's uh level two
i would propose that we ask the mp
jeffrey cox to explain why this is the
case
and to make representations to
government
that we should not be in this position
north of exeter
i don't know how you feel about that but
i do think that uh
you know it seems all the booed is in uh
lower
lowest level and uh and we are not
oh second nature you
um anybody wish to speak on that
yes please jeff certainly
carry on uh
chair i'm i'm concerned first of all
i don't think it's our place to be a a
a lobby organization for central
government but secondly as has been
explained
um this time round they've done it
by county because that is the only
area that people are accurately able to
identify with
and when they did it in lower or smaller
group areas before
it basically people were able
too easy to say that they didn't know
where they were
or anything else so it's been defined as
by
by county um yeah it's tough but
you know if one goes for a popular
decision then you're never gonna get uh
anything on this but i really don't
think that you know if people
if people don't don't like it write to
your mp this is a central government
thing it's not
it's not our business surely thank you
uh well obviously i disagree with you
about that i do think it is our business
to have a view
uh and also i think uh you know as
somebody who's lived in north denver all
my life i'm gonna assure you councilman
that there is a clear dividing line
between the north and south of devon
there would be none of that confusion
that you've got up north
all right councillor leather is the next
one on the list
thank you chair well i was going to
second your proposal because i think
this government
have handled this this virus issue all
year long
abysmally absolutely abysmally and to
move us up left cornwall now in
tier one and to move all of devon into
tier two when torridge
have got one of the lowest incidence
race rates
which i'm pleased about in the country
is absolutely a scandal
and it's just [ __ ] packet back of a [ __ ]
packet politics that
this government and i'm absolutely
scandalized by them
thank you for that well i didn't i meant
to mention also that one of the reasons
why we're in this
position is because of our capacity
uh for uh hospitalization and health
well of course we have campaigned um
and expressed a view in the past uh
council newton over the business of
closure of uh
cottage hospitals at uh torrington and
holdsworthy
and now it's sort of pigeons coming home
to roost because we're now being
penalized because we
they they say that we don't have the
capacity to deal with uh
the kobe situation councillor mckenzie's
next
councillor mckenzie yeah i was just
having trouble muting
um i don't think that we should be uh
writing to the government about this
uh particularly because sticklepath has
got one of the highest rates
in the county per header population
there are students there that come from
biddyford there have been two
year groups from benefit college chat um
i
know of people that work there that have
covered it's closer than we think
um and to relax and sort of like to
to go on about you know um
we shouldn't be doing this and we
shouldn't be doing that it's the
decision that the government and the
professionals and the
experts that have done this um
why should we argue with with that when
you know
who are we to put um uh wealth before
health you know
it's it's on our doorstep it's gonna be
killing people
you know i think that they're doing the
right thing probably more by luck and
judgment but you know
that's by the by that's my opinion thank
you
council next
answer jones thank you thank you chair
i have to agree with councillor newsome
on this one we are not a lobby group and
i think that this seems to
largely be political posturing on the
national stage which we don't have
anything to do with
i think it's foolish for us to say that
we know better
than the scientific advisors they're the
ones who have the data and are looking
at this
so i i think it would be a bizarre for
us to claim
that we have all the facts and are able
to make that decision
um and also i'm unaware of a clear
dividing line between north and south
them and
to which we can adhere to so no i agree
with council of newton we shouldn't be
writing on this it should be for
individuals to contact the mp
themselves if that's what they feel they
want to do thank you
country hutchins next um i don't
necessarily disagree with you
um but what i would say is that i'm not
saying that we should complain about
we're in tier two
but maybe just um to highlight that
maybe going forward they might consider
local councils restricting rather than
um devon county um i mean i agree this
is a bit political
um i probably should declare an interest
i'm in hospitality
um but i do think maybe asking him to
consider
bringing the um the areas down um to our
district level
rather than it being county level thank
you
thank you very much um tom there's no
more speakers are there so
i'll take this to the vote there's a no
problem with that is there
tracy stacy sorry
no care good thank you very much
so um christy ready
it's mary i think but mary just to let
you know counselor
councillor heppel's now joined the
meeting chair thank you very much
it was proposed second i mean seconded
by councillor bushby so
where we go okay counselor can i just
ask exactly what
we're um voting on please uh well we're
asking
uh the mp to explain why
why we should be in uh level two
and asking him to uh ask the government
that we should be
taken out of level two and putting level
one
all right okay away we go
okay council about him against
councillor brenton or
councillor bright for
councillor brown
councillor brown four
councillor bushby or
councillor christy
councillor clark against
councillor cottle hunkin
abstain
cancel the dart
abstain
council afford a bit of a habit here
abstain
cancel a cup against
councillor hackett against
councillor ames epstein
councillor harding against
councillor hawkins against
against councillor hobson
councillor hurley very much against
councillor james um as i declared
interest i will work upstate
councillor jones against
councillor langford four
council of laws against
councillor leather or
councillor locke against
councillor golf against
council mckenzie against
councillor manley against
council newton against
councillor pennington next
councillor watson again
thank you
chair that's six four twenty against and
seven abstentions
thank you christy well that's clearly
lost
the the um the other item would bring
your attention was to do with the
creamery at torrington is there any
update on that
please um
chair i understand there's a
presentation and information given to
um members a week ago on friday
and i understand that stacy is going to
attend torrention town council to update
members there
um in in the new year i think we've been
asked to do
that in january right
thank you for that so number six is uh
questions under procedural rule a9 we
don't have any do we
no chair no so number seven is the major
contracts update
uh now we need we will need to go sort
of in and out of part two on this one
i'm afraid but
some of it is for the public domain and
some of it is
commercially sensitive so uh steve is
going to
lead on this please uh thanks chair so
i'll
i'll start off with all the the part one
item so um obviously you've got a
members have a short report
in front of you predominantly updating
where we are but obviously some
information is excluded because some of
the
uh details have been subject to ongoing
discussions with 16
10. so remember to recall that you're
meeting
on the 26th of october he resolved to
support 1610 with the sum of money
140 000 covering the remaining
months of this financial year
part of that money was in respect of the
the period for the all the centers have
been closed
which at that time was between march
and october um the intention was that
1610
were then able to reopen
torridge pool with effect from
the beginning of november the 2nd of
november but obviously in that
intervening period
in that week the prime minister
announced on the saturday evening the
31st of october as
this second lockdown period which took
effect
uh from the fifth of november the run
through
runs through to the 2nd of december so
1610
started mobilizing to open the second of
november and obviously clearly didn't
do so because of that that closure
um ms will be aware obviously that's
torrington pool there's works continuing
with the roof uh following the discovery
of asbestos
there so that work is ongoing and likely
to conclude
in the new year our third center
tollsworthy members challenged some of
the
assumptions being put forward that the
the site was
unable to operate in a covered
secure format and asked
officers to explore further the
options for us being able or for 1610
being
able to operate uh that center
and that's the the bits of information i
was going to update members
with first of all so we've been
discussing
with officers from 1610 the the possible
opening
and the costs of support that might
involve um early on in the in the
process
1610 had indicated two items a that
holes worthy was unaffordable or doesn't
provide
value for money in terms of operating
and secondly as i said it couldn't
operate in a coverage secure
manner
our property team has been on site
and identified some
changes that could make access
and exit to the center
proper in terms of the the current
covered restrictions
and ada and the team are visiting the
site over the next couple of days to
discuss those
options with officers and the costs
of potential changes
um we've also revisited the the cost
provided by
1610 in terms of operating
at the center and in similar on a
similar basis as
as torrent torridge pool they've
indicated that
member memberships and member visits
would be
around circa 50 to what they'd normally
expect now in terms of the the figures
they'd provided
and they are figures that 1610 provided
not torrid figures
they indicated that in this current year
uh pre-covered uh january february
march the average monthly
number of visits to the center was
around 340.
so based on a 50 usage
for the current foreseeable future they
would base their estimates on that being
around 150
visits per month so around six or seven
or five or six people per day and the
costs they've given us
for operating the facility on that basis
is 20 000 pounds per month
now there are some other issues around
holdsworthy and
adrian's visiting the site tomorrow to
look at what is
also needed to mobilize the facility
obviously it's been
out of operation for a number of months
so there'll be some other matters around
maintenance
costs and so forth still to be
determined
and still would need to be done before
before the center is
opening um so before we
move into part two as there's some
commercially sensitive material
i need to share with members uh the
other aspect is
uh torridge pool so we've been
discussing with 1610
now that they're able to reopen uh from
this wednesday the 2nd of december when
the
lockdown current lockdown period ends
and they're working towards
opening torridge pool and gym
on wednesday subject to
final inspection to make sure the site
and the facilities are
safe and for the proper water testing to
make sure
all the the necessary chemicals etc are
at a
standard um for safe operation
um the other item to bring to members
attention is obviously at your last
meeting
you agreed to pay of the hundred and
forty thousand 116
000 which was in respect of costs
incurred for closure so once the
facilities are closed 1610
incurred uh we're still incurring costs
but not receiving
income from membership so at your
discretion
um you considered that it was
appropriate
to support 1610 with those costs and if
you recall you agreed to pay those costs
equally over the the five remaining
months
of the this financial year november to
march
um 16 said 10 said they would consider
that offer and have since come back
and asked that that money be paid
on a more upfront basis so they've asked
that
we and or members consider
paying march to october now
which would be 67 000 pounds
september and october
which was estimated then at 49 000
paid upon invoice which they have just
done although those estimated figures
for september and october have been
revised upwards to 68 000
and they'd be expecting that payment in
december although i would
stress we are in discussion with them
over
why those costs have increased from 49
000 to 68 000
so that's under current discussion and
then from november onwards
uh the payments to be paid in the month
following
uh the submission of an agreed and
accepted
invoice um so chair the other things to
to consider um as i said first of all
i'd ask members that you consider moving
into part two so we can share with you
some of the more
commercially sensitive information that
you may need
to make your decision thank you uh
steve um we i do have a couple of uh
speakers
which um we'll start with cancer
hutchings
all right thank you chair um i just
wanted to say uh about the importance of
holesworthy
being where we are rurally um
on the side of torridge i've had lots of
representations
old and young who are pleading for that
center to be open
and it is part of our strategic plan for
torridge
for health and well-being i just want to
say the importance of that for halsey
um i do query the numbers i've been um
or i spoke about this before with
members uh just query the usage
and i i hope if the facility is
um good enough
because i think there's been issues over
the years but i think if it's good
enough then people will use it
thank you very much chair thank you
uh councillor jones
thank you char i just like to echo what
councillor hutchins has just said
and i believe it is absolutely
imperative that we get this open again
um there may be those who think that
people from wholesaling
can travel elsewhere but i don't think
that's good enough i think this facility
and wholesomely needs to remain there
and needs
needs to be open once more at this
current time we we need this
this vital service to help our
president's
mental well-being their physical
well-being and i hope that we can get
this
open again as soon as possible to serve
both wholesomely and the surrounding
morality
thank you thank you councillor h you're
next
thank you chair uh yes i'm just gonna
ask steve
about the uh uh torridge pool being open
um is there any restrictions to numbers
to them to the
to the members of the public going in
the pearl and
and what is the safeguarding going to be
in place
in changing rooms and things like that
because
that probably is the biggest problem i
should imagine
um but just to ask if if those two
questions and
also is is the gym going to be open down
there as well
um steve can you answer that um chair
yes there
there'll obviously be restrictions on
numbers and it'll be for 1610 to manage
the
the numbers in a culvert compliant way
so much like i guess our buildings
they will have a specific number depend
or determined by the size of the
facility and the types of equipment
in there that will determine the numbers
uh
the numbers of users they have in there
um
so i know from personal experience that
that's often managed by online bookings
so you book a slot
uh for a specific time so they can
easily manage the the numbers in the
building
uh with regards to any safeguarding
matters
again that's for 1610 as our control
contractor to to manage
clearly there are differences in the way
pools are operating currently to be
covered uh compliant with
uh many centres operating on the basis
that people will arrive at the pool at
the facility
readily changed and ready to get in the
pool
and equally access the building and not
necessarily
not necessarily using changing room
facilities and that's something
that seems to be operating at other
centers
thank you councillor next yes thank you
very much
chair i would just like to ask
councillor hutchins through the chair
how many people have actually um
lobbied him and written to him in
support of the pool
and how does that reflect and the number
of people that say
wanted the beds to be reopened in the
hospital which is one of the burning
issues we have
and people come to me over that but they
don't come to me
over the issue of the swimming pool and
holds worthy so point of order mr
chairman
point of order councilman golf yes
okay ward members don't have to justify
themselves to non-ward members on this
council
if there's one two three people or three
hundred people council hutchins
is to represent those people council
hackett is not hose worthy
so why is he then bringing it up having
a dig is it a dig before no
no no no no i'll respond to that chair
yeah wait yeah people not not interested
in your responses
let's just get on with the meeting
councilmember golf please
okay if i could respond to that
it is a burning issue for the whole of
this area
because i live in hollsworthy rural
people
from my ward do attend swimming pools
they frequent mainly ruby oak pool
which is about four or five miles from
holesworthy
they frequent woodford bridge pool they
also frequent
butte which is further away so bearing
in mind
we have heard a report from our chief
executive
that perhaps half a dozen people
will be using this pool during covid and
during the period
from january to march we had 340 people
using
i am simply testing the evidence which i
think is only fair to do
how many people have contacted
councillor hutchins
with regard to this matter and to give
some sort of benchmark
how many people have contacted him about
reopening the beds
in holes which is a much more burning
issue so i'm just trying to test the
evidence
to better inform councillors and i think
it merits a reply
thank you chair thank you cancer
hutchins you you can reply you're not
obliged to but
if you wish to please
answer um i would just reply
i'll just reply and say i have uh many
in fact um like i say old and young um
groups of youngsters football club it's
not just about the swimming pool it's
about the whole center
and without listing the exact number
because i'm not sure without going
through
emails and facebook messages and verbal
um there are a lot of old people use
that every morning
and i appreciate you're not in the
you're not in holesworthy you're out of
hosley so yes ruby
rubio i don't deny that but there is
still a great need in holesworthy
um and but that could be said i'm sure
councillors from biddeford and
torrington have always had many people
asking for their centers to be open
um you know i'm not making it out i
don't have specific numbers i'm sure i
could find them if it was really
necessary
but i don't believe that's necessary at
the moment okay so
if i could have the right to respond i
think no no no no i think we've i think
we've
dealt with that now thank you okay but i
have no further
i'm better informed but have no better
understanding and i think it's very
wrong with councillor hutchins
to make a sweeping statement without
backing up the numbers
thank you oh yeah i think it's it boils
down to a matter of opinion at the end
of the day
so i'm going to go to councillor hurley
now thank you chair
um i fully respect councillor hutchins
and jones
as as members for trying to get the um
pool opened again
holdsworthy but i'm a bit concerned
about the numbers and the amount of
money that's going into the pool
to get it open it sounds to me it's
going to be more like a bottomless pit
the way things are going however we
shall see
when adrian comes back with his team to
say how much it's going to cost to
make it covered kobe friendly but as i
say i'm a little bit concerned how the
numbers seem to be rising from 1610
to get a pool open for diminishing
numbers of customers
thank you chair thank you can i just
come back please through the chat uh
okay
quickly um just to say uh council hurley
i have not said i support giving 1610 a
penny
what i have said is the importance of
that swimming pool and leisure center
um personally my personal opinion is we
don't give them a penny but that's my
own personal opinion obviously that will
go into part two later on
yes okay thank you for that counselor
back briefly chair please
just briefly i i fully agree with you
council hutchins i've never said you've
you've
support giving 1610 money because i'm in
a similar position
of similar thought to you it's just that
what listen to um
uh steve's report this evening it seems
we are putting more money into there to
try and open
the facility for diminishing numbers and
as a business if we were a business we
wouldn't even look at that i wouldn't
think
thank you right thank you councillor
dart
councillor dart thank you chair sorry
just
couldn't believe i could get a word in
edgeways
join the club i do wish you could sort
yourselves out before a meeting please
i'm inviting one another at the meeting
thank you you go
go ahead thank you just to say
that as ward member for succumb and
brabady
um that i would be negligent if i didn't
pass on
the expressions of dismay um when i
reiterated at the parish council
meetings that
whole city pool would not reopen it
wasn't just from barry parsons
there were some um residents who really
did express that there genuinely is a
use for that pool
and they really would like it open asap
um because they genuinely do miss it so
it is rural you know outside of holes
with thee look further afield because
there are
there is a need there but again i don't
condone
paying 16 10. right thank you
councillor harding
yes just to echo what uh council dog
said i do i'm a
ward member of uh succumb and property
and a lot a lot of people do meet up
down there so yes there is a need for it
but
i agree with all the others uh 1610
i'm not so sure about it thank you thank
you i'm going to cancel james and then
we're going to move into part two we'll
do once i've done the other two items on
the agenda
thank you charles just suggests we when
we debate figures we move into part two
yeah well um i represent the
rural area around holdsworthy in fact
the
ward of pi worthy actually joins onto
holes where they
quite literally and when the next hosing
development goes on it will almost be
into pie worthy
so it is important to the rural areas
and we've had longest
discussions about this so i think it's
time to move on yeah right okay thank
you for that
well i'm going to um go now to we've got
to deal with
number eight on the agenda petitions we
don't have any of them
uh number nine notice emotion we have
none of them
so i propose we move into part two
um secondary please i'll second that
chair
thank you so uh
who's it gonna do mary is it you're
doing the roll call
[Music]
brown
counter brown or she got a problem with
my uh mute button sorry
counselor bush b
oh councillor ford
four councillor cup four
councillor hackett four
councillor haynes four
[Music]
oh
against
council mackenzie four
councillor manly for
councillor newton four
councillor pennington
councilor watson oh